potts to green les robots au service de
l'agriculture
le nom de ce projet qui permet à 10
élèves du lycée district maritime de
valencia en espagne il ya dix jeunes
allemands de l'école à augusto bender de
mosbach d'être ici avec de jeunes
collègues de joseph zobel durant deux
ans ils travailleront sur un système de
serre robotisé pour améliorer la
biodiversité
outre l'intérêt technique de ce projet
surtout que des jeunes arrivent à se
connaître que des peuples différents
mais des cultures différents apprennent
à se connaître à s'apprécier
sachant que par la suite nos élèves vont
partir en allemagne et en espagne
puisque chaque chaque groupe revisite
les deux autres pays arrivé vendredi
dernier les délégations allemandes et
espagnoles font connaissance avec la
martinique
du pur plaisir pour tout le monde ici en
en martinique
ok c'est une faune il est en allemagne
et c'est libère c'est très triste et
et c'est joli ici je suis très heureuse
à devoir les communes les élèves
travaillent ensemble ils sont très
jeunes et mais ils en sont très
exigeantes et à loire amont éditions de
l'avenir est très spécifiques seront qui
ce qu'ils vont faire dans l'avenir
quant à nos jeunes lycéennes première
sciences de l'ingénieur un seul credo
travail et s'ouvrir à l'autre et
échanger
le plus important c'est le projet mais
c'est avant tout une chance de pouvoir
partager une culture nos langues et nos
manières de vivre et le projet passe
avant tout mais c'est avant tout quelque
chose de bien les élèves d'européens
sont hébergés dans des familles
d'accueil
ensuite et pour poursuivre le projet no
martiniquais se rendront à valence en
octobre puis en allemagne en février
prochain